boldly Ezra wields nothing but the force
in this fight with Shin even using it to
hold back one of her lightsaber swings
it's an awesome moment in the midst of a
frantic fight and it proves just how
strong Ezra has become as a force user
for reference in the Disney plus series
Obi-Wan Kenobi The Fearsome and
immensely powerful Darth Vader uses a
similar technique during his brief clash
with rava Vader uses a force to prevent
several of us strikes from landing and
even prevents her specialized
double-bladed lightsaber from spinning
these aren't the only Force users who
have nailed this impressive ability
however Ezra and Vader's move have also
been depicted on the big screen via the
Star Wars sequel Trilogy in the rise of
Skywalker Ray and kylo cross Sabers in
the riage of the second Esa Ray briefly
stops kylo Ren's red lightsaber by using
the force prompting him to do the same
when she attacks moments later